hello everyone and welcome to another
really really awesome and important game
from the penultimate round of the 2022
tata still chess masters it's fabiana
caruana vs magnus carlsen and if carlson
draws this or wins this he is the winner
of the uh this uh year's edition of the
tata still chess masters uh as we still
don't know uh daniel left the tournament
and even if fabi wins uh this this game
uh then magnus gets a free point in the
last round against uh dubois unless uh
there are some talks that if do both
tests negative then he can come back and
play against magnus in the final round
so we still don't know what's happening
there we'll probably know tomorrow uh
but yeah let's return to the game as
it's quite an exciting one so uh old
rivals they've played the world chess
championship match in 2018 in london if
you guys remember and they will repeat a
line they played it there but not for
for a lot of moves so fabi with the
white pieces opens with e4 uh magnus
replies with c5 as he did in every game
in their wheelchair championship match
with knight to f3 knight to c6 and the
bishop to b5 again we have the igneous
medina rossolimo attack uh and g6 by
magnus so uh he
this worked very well for him this is
what he sticks with we have castles and
now bishop to g7 and now the first two
times when uh fabi played the magnus in
the world chess championship match he
captured on c6 but now he goes for c3
and also
it's different than the third time they
played i think this game five where rook
to e1 was played uh
so those were the attempts from the
world's championship match but here fabi
tries c3 and here we deviate uh from the
match with knight to f6 rook to e1 now
defending the pawn and here magnus
castle so sort of inviting whites to
play e5 but that's not really good
because after e5 and knight here the
knight is well much better placed on d5
than an
f6 and if you play something like d4 for
example captures captures
black will challenge your overextended
center and black will be well even
better here if knight c3 we can even
play bishop to e6 so all right there's
that so after this uh castles with d
four by five striking in the center
right away and now d5 with e5 and knight
the e4
and now okay you could uh capture on c6
this is the the most common move but
fabi goes for bishop to e3 obviously he
prepared something very special for
magnus here so c captures on d for c
captures and now queen to b6 the queen
is developed with tempo the bishop is
under attack and now uh usually bishop
captures on c6 is played but here fabi
goes for the extremely rare queen to e2
he defends the bishop and he asks magnus
what is your plan i'm not going to tell
you what my plan is so magnus continues
developing we have bishop to d7 and i
square for the bishop you've connected
your rooks next you can play a6 move the
queen maybe b5 and so on maybe double
rooks on the c file all depends on what
white plays so here bishop back to a4
uh and now uh we have rook a to c8
interestingly you'd think you have
knight captures on d4 with a double
discovery here but you really don't have
to bishop captures on d for your queen
is hanging so you have to pay attention
to that so here rook a to c8 magnus just
continues development and now there is a
game where h3 was played but here we
have knight to c3 just developing a
knight and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game and it's
magnus to move so magnus plays knight
captures on c3 and it makes sense uh you
force white to capture with the b pawn
and now this is uh this is a backwards
uh c pawn now and it's gonna be maybe a
bit difficult to defend so queen back to
d8 by magnus now preparing to push those
queen side pawns and bishop back to b3
we have knight to a5 going after the
bishop and here magnus doesn't want to
capture the bishop he will only capture
the bishop if the rook moves if the rule
doesn't move then you don't want to
capture you give white the uh the
semi-open a file uh but here fabi does
play rook a to c1 as it does make sense
you wanna at some point play c4 and now
if magnus captures the bishop here you
will connect your pawns and then you
will have even more support for for the
c for push uh but this is interestingly
exactly what magnus goes for he plays
knight captures on b3 we have eight
captures and now queen to b6 uh
returning the queen to the uh b6 square
going after the b3 pawn and now queen to
a2 fabi nicely defends it and only now
we have a5 so uh
of course it's uh evident that fabi
wants to play c4 but by playing a5
magnus actually stops this because now
if you go c4 or rather he doesn't stop
it he even invites it because now if
c4a4 maybe and it's a really crazy
position where black is threatening to
create a pass pawn already on b3 and if
you capture here then you no longer
defend c4 so then you can capture on c4
so it's really really crazy so after a5
fabi first goes queen to a3 he attacks
the weak e7 pawn magnus defends it and
only now uh he goes for c4 so he thought
that the queen being an a3 would have
would be
more advantageous for him so here magnus
captures d captures on c4 even though a4
is still an idea here but now magnus
prefers d captures on c4 b captures and
now queen to a6
so what do you do the c4 pawn is
attacked you have to play something fabi
pushes the pawn to c5 and it's not ideal
now as the bishop uh the bishop is here
hitting the d4 pawn so uh it's not the
greatest of structures because magnus
plays bishop to c6 and now you have a
hole here on d5 and it's not going to be
easy for white to to advance this so
it's hard to say will this pawn mass in
the center be stronger or will the past
a pawn or maybe some other pass pawn on
the queen side be stronger so here rook
to b1
with some ideas of kicking the queen
further back with rook to b6 and here
magnus goes a4
there's also the very interesting b5
that magnus didn't like uh the idea is
you sacrifice upon uh for the moment c
captures on b6 you allow this alpha and
now after e6 for example uh d5
there's no way to keep the pawn black
can just easily win it he can double
rooks on the b file and win that pawn so
here white would have to give up the
pawn we're going to capture here and now
we would have this past pawn against
this best pawn
uh with perfect play should be equal
but okay after rook to b1 we have a4 and
now we have rook e to c1 uh
rook the b4 would also be very nice for
fabi but he decides to play rook a to c1
and now magnus plays rook c to d8 also
b5 still an idea but he decides to bring
the rook to d8 uh and now comes knight
to d2 yeah and here
rook to b6 is kind of preferred because
after rook to b6 magnus has to bring the
queen all the way back
and then uh well
the queen is just uh
the queen just occupies a lesser square
uh because here if you go queen to e2
which of course you can then we just
kick the queen back uh rook to b2 we are
gonna play queen a6 and now we repeat so
if uh you know but obviously fabi not
very much interested in draw here uh but
another thing after rook to b6 yeah you
could just bring the queen to a8 and
then
the game continues but five we played
knight to d2 and this allows magnus to
actually infiltrate the position with
the queen because the e2 square is now
much much better so queen to e2 now rook
b2 isn't really doing anything
and now how do you play this it's a
really difficult position where there
only seems to be one
decent move for white uh and that is
knight back to f3 but this is something
that we've discussed many times uh that
um there isn't a player in the world
that will just admit his previous move
was bad so here by moving the right back
you basically admitted that you no
longer have any advantage and that you
now agree that the position is equal
you've just given magnus a very strong
square uh the point of knight to f3 is
that the bishop cannot capture if bishop
captures then uh first we play rook b2
we kick away the queen and now you don't
really have this um queen a6 because we
play g captures on f3 and now white is
definitely better there's uh a lot more
to play for here the rooks will easily
collect both of these pawns and it's
just a much better position for white so
what you will have to do
after this knight to f3 move you're
gonna have to play something like f6 and
then the game continues but it's
incredibly incredibly sharp however
after queen to e2 fabi did not bring the
knight back he played f3 which makes
sense as the bishop is here on this
occupies this beautiful diagonal some of
you definitely want to play also you
prepare maybe knight to e4 in some lines
but
it's actually a move that also loses the
game for fabi or rather brings it very
close to a losing point so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
move that magnus played while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
wonderful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show of course
the movies rook captures on d4 that's
the good stuff point being that after
bishop captures we're going to capture
the knight on d2 we've given up the
exchange but we've um uh we've dealt a
crippling blow to white's central pawn
mass and it's not gonna be easy for
white to play this as you'll see and
once magnus played this rook captures on
d4 the entire twitter uh went crazy it
was really really wild so bishop
captures on the e4 there really isn't
anything better queen captures on d2 and
now rook to d1 and okay situation on the
clock uh 15 minutes for for fabi 21
minutes for magnus and we're only at
move 28 so 12 more moves are needed for
time control to be reached so queen to f
for now and now fabi plays queen to b4
uh here if you ask the engine what what
can white even play here the engine will
just give you rook to d3 rook to d1 we
can double rooks on the d file and hope
for the best there really isn't all that
much you can do here because even though
you're down the exchange uh you're
controlling the the pawns here on the
queen side with your light square bishop
you're gonna win this spawn uh at some
point so that's not really an issue uh
and uh well at some point you can even
play rook to a8 you can start pushing
this pass pawn if the queen moves so
black has a lot to play for whereas a
white is uh
well definitely not spoiled for choice
so here queen to be for by fabi and now
uh what can magnus play and fabi lost
quite a lot of time here he's already
down to four minutes magnus says 21
minutes on the clock uh and here he
could go rook to a8 but that's uh that's
uh really a forcing move he just plays
e6 and he says all right you figure out
a plan you spend your time as you're
very very much low on the clock uh he
also could play bishop captures on e5
but that's in that's an even more
forcing line and fabio was counting on
this and probably spent some time but
here you just allow white to nicely
double up rooks and uh or even rook to
a8 you can now double rooks on the
default rugby to d1 and you've given uh
white something to do however here after
e6 again fabi has to figure out a movie
and he plays bishop to d3 bishop to c3
he offers a queen trade uh but that's
not the way to go again just doubling
rooks on the default that's the only
thing white has in this position and
even that
is questionable so here magnus happily
trades queens we have queen captures and
now what do you do do you capture with
the bishop or with the rook because the
bishop kind of guards this e5 pawn
but let's discuss the rook captures on
b4
so if rook captures on b4 we're gonna
play bishop to f8 and now it doesn't
seem like white has a
white has a good move uh how do you how
do you defend this pawn it's uh not all
that uh uh doable because if
you try with the rook for example we can
play bishop to b5 if you try something
like bishop to d4 then we play rook to
d8 and again it's uh very very hard to
to play this uh there are some very cool
lines here like bishop captures then we
pick up the rook here so you're going to
have to play something like rook c4 but
now we start pushing our pass pawn king
f2 we're going to play rook to a8 put a
rook behind our pass pawn and now well
if something like rook c to c1 we're
going to play a2 and this is just a
monster pass pawn once our bishop comes
to d5 it's gonna guard the dis pawn
guard to this pawn and we're just gonna
have a really really good game so what
you would have to do after rook captures
on b4 and bishop to f8 is in fact rook
to d6 this is what fabi would have to
commit to uh but it's like okay for this
bad position i have the exchange and now
i even have to give back the exchange
i'm i'm not going to play that uh but
even this magnus doesn't have to capture
on d6 he can play rook to a8 and now
after some like king f2 we're gonna play
a3 and pretty much the same idea we're
going to put the bishop on d5 to control
the a2 pawn for example king e2 a2 we're
gonna play bishop to a1 now bishop to a7
we continue bringing the king into the
game and only then will we capture here
and um well just continue pushing for
for our advantage so fabi doesn't like
rook captures here he plays bishop
captures on b4 instead uh at least uh
well he he keeps this pawn so this pawn
remains blockaded but now magnus
captures on e5 we have bishop to a3 now
comes bishop to f6 uh we have king to f2
fabi has to make moves very quickly but
he makes uh very very precise moves
bishop to e7 uh now uh putting putting
pressure on that c5 pawn uh and now you
have to be careful now even ideas like
b5 are possible because you're not going
to be able to capture the pawn as the
bishop will be hanging so here we have
rook to b6 preventing the the
advancement of the b
of the b pawn and now rook to c8 by
magnus you could also try something like
rook to d8 but again for example rook
captures bishop captures we're going to
play rook to b2 now we play f5 and okay
the game continues but um
it's sort of an accomplishment for fabi
not for magnus so magnus just keeps the
pressure there's no need to trade
anything off just uh you know for for
the sake of trade and now we have rook
to d2 by fabian here uh fabi is under a
minute and he still has five more moves
to make before reaching time control so
here we have f6 uh f4 and now e5
offering a pawn trade uh you could also
try to waste more time with h6 than g3
and then capture uh but magnus captures
right away so offers a trade right away
fabi captures magnus captures now rook
e2 goes after the pawn now rook f8 to
check we have king the e1 and now we
have rook to f5 defending the pawn and
now magnus will improve the position of
his pieces as much as he can and then he
will start bringing this king into the
game
if possible via the light squares as uh
fabio only has a dark square bishop so
here we have rook to b1 this is mu 40
and uh fabi has uh reached the time
control he's now given additional time i
think he had like four seconds on the
clock when he made this move
but it's not that like it was uh you
know intense or anything he just made a
very a very calm calculated uh approach
to this so here magnus starts pushing we
have e4 now comes rook to c1 and now
bishop to h for check forcing fabi to
weaken himself on the king side g3 now
bishop to g5 attacks the rook rook to b1
and now rook to f3
uh attacking the bishop here so bishop
back to c1 offering a trade of bishops
but for the moment bishop to f6 there's
no need to
to trade anything we have rook back to
b6 and now we have rook to f5 by magnus
there's also a straightforward win with
bishop to c3 chuck but it requires a lot
of calculation but after king d1 you can
play e3 and that's it the white really
doesn't have a move if you ever capture
this then you allow a3 a2 in that game
over and other than this for example
king here if we're going to play bishop
here pick up this pawn and that's also
one way to win
so after rugby six magnus plays rook to
f5 he goes after the pawn this way now
bishop back to a3 defends the pawn and
only now magnus starts bringing the king
into the game king to f7 we have rooked
f2 offering a rook trade and now even
though magnus could capture he plays
rook to f3 if you want to capture i want
to get my pawn closer to the queening
square so here rook captures pawn
captures king f1 and here magnus played
bishop to d4 and it was in this position
on mu 49 that fabiano corona resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so to give you a a brief
summary of uh of how this would go uh
for example you have to play something
rook to b1 not a lot of things you can
move we're just going to bring the key
into the game and that's it for example
g4 king to d5 we're gonna play h4 king
to e5 and after something like rook to
b4 putting pressure on the bishop
even bishop to e4 and now you can't stop
a bishop to d3 as the pawn covers this
square and after something let's say
bishop to c1 we just deliver this check
kink the e1 we're gonna play f2 checking
d2 and f1 queen and of course now it's
completely winning for black that's yeah
that's why after bishop to d4 fabio
resigned and another brilliant victory
uh against not just a former uh member
of the 2800 club but also a former world
church championship challenger uh
fabiana corona so here magnus manages to
pull off a win in a line that was used
in the world chess championship match
but here
fabi obviously tried to
maybe
throw magnus off guard with that
deviation but magnus was very much
prepared for it and so we don't forget
these are the standings after the
penultimate round uh so magnus leading
the tournament with eight and a half out
of twelve with seven and a half we have
mamadara when rapport uh then with seven
on each geary uh yes panko with six and
a half then with six we have invited to
van forest uh and fabiano caruana now
after this loss with five and a half
young sister of duda and sam shankland
pragernando with four and a half grand
elias with four and daniel lubov with
three and a half who has left the
tournament uh so now uh it seems that uh
if daniel does not appear in the final
round magnus is just uh just wins by
default because he will have nine and a
half points and closest mommy darwin
rapport can uh reach uh is eight and a
half but if uh for uh you know somehow
dubo appears uh he's tested negative and
then he can play again if it's even you
know according to regulations uh and he
beats magnus uh then
well then we could have a tie
but you know that's a big if and i i
don't think anyone knows anyone anything
about this yet so uh you know you guys
will be informed at some point tomorrow
definitely
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it magnus gets his long awaited
the victory in classical against the
fabiana corona i would like to thank
deepak robert
vladimirovich
and isaac
for akata for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day